on l'a dit plusieurs fois sur le déclin
et bien pas du tout le créateur de sex
machine james brown est toujours là et
bien là
soixante-six ans après 46 ans de
carrière il a donné hier soir au
festival d'istres son seul et unique
concert en france reportage michel
mompontet philippe naudy james brown
n'est comme aucune autre star d'abord
lui n'arrive pas pour un concert lui
daigne seulement quitté son royaume pour
propager la bonne parole celle du funk
bien sûr le funk musiques noires dont il
est le prophète
le créateur le parrain adulé ses fans
ont un peu vieilli
certes et alors ne riez pas jeunes gens
vos grands parents ont sûrement dedans
c'est sûr ifeelgoods et vos parents vous
ont peut être conçue sur sex machine
voilà 50 ans que james brown nous
accompagnent dans un rythme d'enfer 140
albums plus tard et monsieur bois on a
toujours la classe comme si le temps
glisser sur lui un pacte avec le diable
pour ralentir le tempo de sa vie je
m'adonnais un style il m'a donné le nom
de james brown gauche je ne m'appelait
que james jose assad
c'est dieu qui a trouvé le nom de james
donne un nom de scène précis et qui
frappe et comme depuis 46 ans chaque
soir prière avant concerne ma musique
c'est une affaire de mathématiques
spirituel ça ne s'invente pas sur le
papier ça vient dans votre tête mais ça
pousse dans votre âme et james brown
dans tout ça je voudrais dire que james
brown est un mec chanceux et que dieu
vous bénisse
vingt minutes plus tard avec 18
musiciens la marmite du festival
d'istres est prêt à bouillir le maître
arrive
à
les gens longtemps dans commencé son
concert par living in america comment
oublier que ce pays justement le
condamne à six fois à la case prison
drogue bagarre comme d'inévitables
clichés condamnant toujours les artistes
noirs américains
les au vu du concert d'hier soir james
brown semble parti pour une tournée au
moins jusqu'en 2070 ils seront bien sûr
plus mais lui mystère hier soir - il en
semblait bien capable